c'était devenu une relique oubliée d'une
autre époque
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
l'abri a repris du service quand les
sirènes d'alarme retentissent les
résidents du quartier dans la ville de
kryviri ils sont invités jusqu'au signal
de la fin du danger
les autorités de la ville tentent de
rendre l'endroit plus accueillant on y a
même construit une scène pour y faire
des concerts et projeter des matchs de
soccer
dans tous les cas s'il y avait une
frappe nucléaire dit-il que Dieu nous en
préserve nous pouvons rester ici
longtemps nous avons aussi fait des
stocks de médicaments appropriés pour
les habitants de la ville au cas dans
les fêtes il est peu probable que tous
ces efforts ne suffisent à sauver bien
des vies en cas d'attaque à l'arme
nucléaire par la Russie
depuis l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine en
février dernier la menace ne recourt à
l'arme nucléaire n'est jamais bien loin
dans le discours de Vladimir Poutine
allusion plus ou moins claires on est
passé à des menaces à peine voilée
depuis l'explosion survenue sur le pont
de Crimée
c'est une volée de missiles
traditionnelle qui s'abat sur les villes
et la population de l'Ukraine mais la
possibilité d'une frappe nucléaire et de
nouveau sur toutes les lèvres
sur les plateaux de télévision russe la
propagande et les discours les plus
extrêmes se déversent de façon
complètement décomplexée
avec tout ce qui se passe sur notre
territoire on ne peut pas écarter une
telle décision de Poutine mais je suis
certain que ce serait en dernier recours
dit-il la réaction du monde devrait être
immédiate en cas d'attaque nucléaire
Poutine doit subir une défaite cuisante
sans délai au l'excès Dany love passe
beaucoup de temps à chercher à
comprendre ce qui se trame dans la tête
du dirigeant de la Russie Vladimir
Poutine a accusé les forces spéciales
ukrainiennes d'avoir l'explosion du pont
qui lui était si cher aujourd'hui la
Russie a arrêté 8 personnes en lien avec
ce que le président a qualifié d'actes
terroristes le barrage de missile qui
fond depuis lundi sur l'Ukraine c'est sa
revanche a-t-il dit
le secrétaire général national de
sécurité et de défense de l'Ukraine est
un Dieu qui s'était réjouit de cette
explosion mais aujourd'hui il se retient
tout juste d'accuser la Russie d'avoir
fait son propre sabotage une excuse pour
frapper sur des civils dit-il
attaque allait se produire dès le 2 ou 3
octobre ça n'a rien à voir avec ce
qu'ils appellent un pont dit-il c'est
une tactique de la Fédération russe
quand les choses commencent à chauffer
il crédit immense problème pour la
population c'est un pays terroriste ces
dirigeants sont des criminels de guerre
ils peuvent penser à n'importe quoi la
vie humaine n'a aucune valeur pour eux
dans les rues de grive on s'accroche à
cette vie que l'on veut plus que tout
calme banal on se garde bien de céder à
la panique mais certains se préparent
Arthur croit que ce n'est qu'un chantage
de la part de Vladimir Poutine il n'en
est pas moins sur ses gardes
dit-il nous connaissons les protocoles
d'action personnellement j'ai un abri
j'ai de la nourriture propre de l'eau
potable tout est scellé j'ai aussi des
respirateurs
ou russe et ukrainien se croyaient
frères il faut être suicidaire pour
avoir recours au nucléaire dit-elle
les Russes vont mourir nous allons
mourir et puis nous détruirons la
planète qui voudrait de ça et la menace
nucléaire ne vient pas que des armes
tactiques encore aujourd'hui la centrale
nucléaire de zapporisa a été privé
d'électricité après une frappe de
missile ces réacteurs alimentés par des
groupes générateurs une situation qui ne
peut être que temporaire au pays de la
catastrophe de Tchernobyl on comprend
bien le jeu dangereux qui se joue ici
Marie-Eve Bédard Radio-Canada Kiev